ça va ça va bien vous sera bien ravi de
vous voir
ils dépendent pour voulant signer des
autographes les gens ils vont attendre
il faut absolument que je vous met
derrière un piano et ben on va derrière
un piano on va s'approcher d'un piano
dans les seuls qui est donc on essaie
mot qui veut plus comme ça au point mort
ici c'est sûr ça aide vraiment le fruit
et non pas sur scène alors d'accord
merci sur scène on y va
pardon excusez nous
pardon et ses excuses et nous serons
face à la menace et la dame en vaux
michel mes enfants je vis tu es jolie
paris fille
voilà il ya un piano là alors ça c'est
très beau parce que ça une scène déserte
il ya toujours une flamme c'est un peu
comme à l'église
l attitude bien voulu tenir orangerie
dire que le jésus dans le temps et sur
scène on est remarqué c'est pareil y'a
plus rien il ya toujours mis lui n'en
tire que c'est très rare la vie et reste
toujours beau c'est rigolo
enfin ça ressemble un briano non ce
qu'il faut que je vous dise avant tout
est ce que sinon on a presque oublié
c'est que ma femme elle m'a dit si un
jour dans ta vie tu rencontres michel
legrand et demande lui de jouer juste un
petit bout des moulins de mon coeur
voilà c'est pour elle c'est comme
c'était la saint valentin
[Musique]
à
comme une pierre que l'on g
le vif des ruisseaux
qu'ils laissent derrière elles
des milliers de ronds dans l'eau
comme un manager de lille
avec ses chevaux des points
comme un anneau de saturne ballon le
carnaval
le chemin de rendre que font sans cesse
les heures
le voyage autour du monde
d'un tournesol
dans le sable
tu fais tourner le ton nom
tous les moulins de mort
[Musique]
on
un écheveau de l'aisne
entre les mains d'un enfant
les mots d'une rengaine
pris dans les alpes et du vent
oublions de neige
comme avant
de beaux lots
sur les chevaux de norvège sur des
moutons de céans
comme le chemin de ronde que font sens
ça se désole
le voyage autour du monde autour de ça
tu fais tourner de tonton
tous les moulins de bon
en
merci beaucoup c'est un très beau cadeau
que vous fait ma femme et à beaucoup
d'autres gens vous êtes génial et dites
moi c'est pourquoi cet intérêt après
intel avec barbra streisand maintenant
le le film tiré de singer vous avez un
intérêt particulier pour le parlement de
juifs comme ça pour le côté violon sur
le toit
écoutez c'est drôle mais mais j'ai rien
de particulier aux deux spéciales
simplement par hasard il se trouve que
je vais à presque à chaque fois qu'il ya
vraiment un sujet vraiment je vais
naturellement entend bien demander oui
c'est drôle léger j'ai fait récemment la
vie de golda merde en exemple dont la
musique
j'avais fait des tas de choses était
bébé c'est pas seulement ça ce qui est
très curieux aussi américaines ont
demandé des fois de faire des choses des
films sur les noirs des films oui alors
je n'ai jamais ricains ils disent que
vous êtes un meilleur compositeur de
musique américaine que sa flamme au top
les membres mais cette fois on les
connaît c'est vachement gentil parce que
parce que la musique la musique
ouais elle est partout il n'y a pas de
croix il n'y a pas de pays
quand vous étiez petit vous habitiez ou
quand j'étais petit j'habitais en
banlieue j'habitais à asnières et je
passais ma vie près d'un piano par an il
nous faisait quoi bon mon père était
musicien même et il est parti acheter
des allumettes rang j'avais 3 ans
d'accord et il est parvenu à j'ai pas
beaucoup vu ses mornes et on sait
exactement comme le comme jean michel
jarre a fallu mettre les jamais revenue
mais s'attendent bientôt
maintenant ils sont réconciliés depuis
le temps oui alors vous avez vous
commencé comment avec le piano comme ça
tout seul vous étiez un peu un peu
triste et vous souhaitez solitaire moi
les autres enfants ça m'ennuyait
j'aimais alors j'ai dessiné mais que ça
alors j'ai c'est marrant parce que
j'écoutais à la radio des chansons ça je
m'amusais à les retrouver au piano à
deux doigts j'ai recherché les harmonies
pour voir comme ça et leur ma mère s'est
aperçu très vite que c'était une
véritable envie et elle m'a fait donner
des leçons tout de suite et je suis
rentrée au conservatoire
quand même très très jeune a 10 ans un
génie quand même un petit peu ça mais
j'étais doué c'est à dire que faites
vous j'allais vite et tout ça et puis à
l'âge de 10 ans à 20 ans pendant 11 ans
j'ai fait toutes mes études là-bas avec
les grands mères
parce que je voulais vraiment après oui
une vraie technique fait de
l'apprentissage au maire j'en ai fait
plein de places est magnifique et très
famille parce que votre soeur elle
chantait vachement swingle singers
magnifique double 6 tous à ses blessures
c'est la bonne époque c'était bien ça
revient la presse évoque le jack ce
qu'on appelle le jack maintenant c'est
l'homme la bonne façon de chanter les
gens qui chantent très bien capella très
belles mélodies
les groupes vocaux se connaissaient
portrait 5 d'un nouveau grand repris à
ou deep is your love des bee gees
simplement a cappella juste dévoile son
combien d'euros supposons quatre ou cinq
des noirs américains très très bien et
vous connaissez le texte fixe le marbre
c'est un groupe de six noir à macaq
appelle la csu bray un vrai retour de
ses armes et ses sublimes
[Musique]
e
donc
quel os et jaune
jo
m
nous avons sauvé je suis mal au caire ou
et qu'elle aurait toujours
google wave
juin jacques demy vous l'avez rencontré
comment la première fois jacques demy
c'était je venais de faire un film moi
en 1959 au début de la nouvelle vague
quoi l'un des premiers c'était un film
de françois reichenbach
il s'appelle d'amérique insolites et
alors tous les metteurs en scène la
nouvelle vague de jacques demy tout tout
tout tout les jeunes afin qu'ils
commencent et l'aimable m'ont téléphoné
à côté ça et c'est comme ça que j'ai
déjà volaille mais il venait de finir
son premier film s'appelait lola oui il
m'a dit vous voulez faire la musique ça
alors j'ai dit oui et puis on a fait
connaissance puis on est devenu
rapidement des amis inséparables puis on
s'est toujours dit le premier jour on a
joué au faucon par la musicale ces sacs
noirs tient mais ça tout va et on a fait
quelques basses et culte ça a maintenant
ça y est quoi je veux dire les
parapluies de cherbourg ou demoiselles
de rochefort on le passe dans des
émissions de télé les jeunes de 17 ans
avant tout c'est génial il ya des
moments comme ça dans mon voisinage al
aroui les écoutes ça ils chantent tous à
park c'est pas embêtant donc d'être un
peu un monument historique non attendez
on joue pas non mais bon on a tout le
temps là bon d'accord mais j'en profite
et là bas ça il me reste à faire plein
de trucs que j'ai peur j'ai à dire c'est
tu sais je vous à l'avenir comme ça à
l'horizon à main on n'aperçoit pas
encore vous voulez perdre juste un truc
pour moi moi bien sûr c'est vous savez
dans les parapluies de cherbourg à la
fin quand on est sur le quai de la gare
la main sur cette image dans la tête et
on voit le train qui s'en va avec marc
et cherbourg et tout ça juste un petit
bout comme ça
[Musique]
où
e
et
oh
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu